tous les jours de la même manière ou ça
dépend de ton état
ça dépend un peu de mon état le plus
sérieusement tu t'échauffes le moins tu
as de risques
et une grosse blessure l'année dernière
je me suis fait une fraction de fatigue
j'ai trop poussé dessus par ma situation
elle est vraiment anxiogène dans le sens
où je faisais des rôles que je pouvais
pas laisser passer ma chance et j'avais
super mal et j'ai continué de danser
dessus jusqu'au point où j'avais presque
plus à marcher tu vois la carrière d'un
danseur elle est elle est courte et on a
toujours cette pression de l'âge tu vois
au dessus de nous dire
mais si je sais pas si à 25 ans je suis
pas premier danseur au sujet ou s'il
faut que je sois absolument danser
l'étoile avant de 30 ans et tout ça et
du coup on a toujours ce truc un peu de
stress où on a toujours peur de
rater le bon moment tu vois ou de rater
sa chance
[Musique]